MALE SPEAKER: A few weeks
ago, I went to a comedy show
in the city, and I got
talking to this Irish guy who
had this very
interesting background.
He had this debilitating
fear of public speaking.
So the obvious way to
approach conquering that fear
is, of course, becoming
a stand-up comedian.
So as a non-comedian,
he pretended
to be a stand-up comedian
for a year to get over
his fear of public speaking.
An interesting
way to attack it--
but in the process of
doing that, he learned
a lot about comedy techniques,
about stand-up techniques,
and about public
speaking in general.
And he took all
these ideas, and he
thought about how to make more
effective presentations, which
we had a long discussion
about because I care deeply
about public
presentations and humor
and how to make them
all more engaging.
And he took that information.
He wrapped it up
to it into a book.
And I thought, well, that
sounds like an interesting book.
I'd like to read it someday.
So three days later, there was
an internal email at Google
that said, hey, there's
this author named
David Nihill who has a new book
coming out on public speaking.
Would anybody like to host this?
Well, that's a perfect
opportunity for me
to have an excuse to
actually read his book now.
So here we are, a
few weeks later.
And he's going to
tell us about how
to make more effective
presentations using techniques
of stand-up comedians.
I think we all know and suffer
from public presentations that
could be a heck of a lot more
entertaining than they are.
And there's no reason why
they shouldn't be, except
that maybe people don't
common techniques that
could be used to make them so.
So that's sort of what
the book is about,
and it's about what the
presentation is about.
And please welcome David Nihill.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID NIHILL: Thank you.
Fine introduction.
So I know that sounds
like the worst plan ever.
You're scared of
public speaking,
and you're going to pretend
to be a comedian for a year?
That does not sound
like a good idea.
It 100% was not a good idea.
But at least we've written
it down at this stage.
Thanks for coming.
I always like to ask
who thinks they're not
funny by a show of hands.
So is there anyone who's
like, I'm not funny at all?
So four of you are not
funny, and the rest of you
are really, really funny?
So this will be fine
no matter what I say.
Because we can just call upon
you guys to rock it, right?
Anyone else hate
public speaking?
I totally hate public
speaking, which is ironic
that I'm merely
laying an egg on video
right now here
recording this one.
How many?
Keep the hands up.
I mean like shaking the page
kind of fear public speaking?
That was me, always.
Nobody over here
in the States knew.
Obviously I'm from Ireland
originally with a dodgy accent,
and I went to
university in Ireland.
And all my friends had me
nicknamed shakin' Stevens,
because whenever I
had a bit of paper
in my hand for a
presentation, public speaking,
it would just start moving
around like this all the time,
and I'd start sweating.
And do you know this
feeling at all, anybody?
And it's just getting worse.
And I'm holding the
microphone, and I can't
hold it steady anymore either.
It was always, always,
always that bad for me.
And honestly, I would
have described it
as a crippling fear.
If you ask me, in any way
public speaking for you,
it is a crippling fear.
And that was until a rather
serious phone call that I
got about a friend of mine.
And it was to inform
me that he'd just
suffered a severe
spinal cord injury,
and he might never walk again.
And his insurance
provider cut him off,
and we were trying to come
up with ways, because he
was in no way accepting
this that he was never
going to walk again.
He's like, I'm going
to get back on my feet.
I just need to be able to do
the rehab process to do it.
So we're like, well, as his
friends, we got together.
We're like, let's
start doing fundraisers
to get him back on his feet.
And I just happened to
live next to this guy who
was a touring comedian
and a headlining comedian.
And I was like, hey,
Tim, would you by chance
do this comedy show
fundraiser we're going to do?
I don't know anything about
organizing it or anything,
but let's do it.
And he said yes.
And all my friends
were like, well,
you're naturally
pretty talkative, you
are going to be the host
because you are organizing it.
And I was like, I am not hosting
that never, absolutely no way.
And they were all
just kept at me.
No, no, you have to.
And up to that moment, I
was like there's no way.
I can describe this as
a fear that's crippling.
I mean, faced with a
more serious impact--
the real impact of that
word, I was like, all right,
time to get over this.
So I went, and I did this.
And I was looking
right-- if I had
to get good at public
speaking quickly
and had to get over
this fear, like who's
the best person to study?
Like, where do I get
the information from?
There's books out there.
I don't want to read them all.
I don't really have time.
Where do I get it from?
Who are the true masters?
So I was thinking,
well, comedians
are probably the true
masters of public speaking.
I just read a lot of
Malcolm Gladwell, which
I'm sure you're
very familiar with
and his 10,000 hour rule
that makes a master.
Well, comedians are on stage
more than anybody else.
They take people to
a range of emotions
more so than anybody else.
Let me see what I can get from.
It's a comedy show anyway.
So it'll be pretty
useful, and I don't
want to be that one funny
nervous guy with the shakin'
Stevens moves and
see what happens.
So it went really well.
We raised a good chunk
of money, totally packed.
And it went so well that the
main comedian asked me, like,
literally, like,
hey, Dave, do you
want to open for me at
the Punchline Comedy
Club in a couple of weeks?
And I was like, do I tell him
that I haven't got a clue?
I was like, nah.
Yeah, sure, I'll do that.
So I did it.
And I'd just been
reading-- he's an author.
I'm sure he's been
here at Google before.
You might be familiar
with his work, AJ Jacobs.
He's very much referenced
by in Tim Ferriss's books.
He was known for going deep
into a topic for a year
and writing about it.
And I read his books.
And he'd just done "The
Year of Living Biblically,"
where even though he was Jewish,
followed the rules of the Bible
to the letter of the law,
like so much so he was out
throwing stones at adulterers.
It was pretty cool.
I was like, right.
Maybe I'll keep this
going for a year.
Maybe I'll get
Tim Ferriss on it.
I was very influenced by
him breaking things down,
80/20 principle,
trying to figure out
what are the techniques
that are most effective.
And I'll do it for a full year.
And I was like, well, I've
just left a corporate job.
And if I tell my
friends I'm going
to put all my effort into
being a comedian for a year
with actually no objective of
being a full time comedian,
and very little potential income
from this choice for a year,
they're going to
think I am bonkers.
So I was like, I better
make up a stage name,
because I don't want people
tagging me on Facebook doing
all this comedy stuff,
and I hate public speaking
in the first place.
So I got a bit carried away.
And we came up with Irish Dave.
That was the comedian.
And this kind of
became the book,
was my learning along the way.
But here I got very much
carried away with this.
Irish Dave doesn't sound like
the most novel stage name
to an Irish person,
but Americans seem
to like it for some reason.
And I went as an
accomplished comedian.
So I was trying to make it
known that I was already
well-versed in
comedy because it's
much easier to get booked in
clubs and festivals that way.
So this was one
of the first shows
I managed to get booked
on, a real highlight.
You can see "Estrogen Entree
with a Side of Balls."
I got to be that side of balls.
As you can see
with all the ladies
names, a real proud
moment for my parents.
I can imagine--
David, glad to see
you've left your corporate job.
When are you going back
to it again, please?
[INAUDIBLE] side of balls.
Loads and loads of festivals,
loads of comedy clubs
all over the US.
And it wasn't all totally nutty.
I learned a lot along the way.
And some of the cooler
ones, are any of you
familiar with NPR's The Moth,
the storytelling series--
true stories told live?
So I was trying to get on
any stage that would have me.
So I went along, told
a story, and I won.
And then they're
like, well, now you
have to go on our
biggest event that they
produce worldwide
is in San Francisco,
in the Castro Theatre.
So that little ant
on stage is me.
And it's 1,400
people there, and I
am about to lay an
egg I am so nervous.
And if you shook
my hand beforehand,
you'd feel like
you'd been assaulted
by a semi-defrosted
mackerel-- like, bad.
I was so nervous.
But you wouldn't know it if
you were in the audience.
So over a year of
experiments, I'd
learned enough to
make it at least look
like I was quite comfortable
where I very much was not
on stage.
And telling that
story that night,
I could never have predicted
what would have happened.
It set off a lot of
really cool stuff
that I'm going to tell you
about by the end of this talk.
So I just want to
give you an overview
some of the things in the book
that I learned along the way
that I think you can
replicate, and in the end
we'll get some questions
going because I
know there's loads around it.
But I just wanted to focus on
what were the techniques that I
was using to do
this along the way
and what I saw from comedians.
Because everyone I saw
along the way in comedy,
they didn't all get
famous as comedians.
In fact, very few of them did.
But every single one of them
got funnier along the way.
They were very much showing that
there was a process behind it.
All of their writing got better.
So there was certain
techniques behind it.
So if I said to you
you can become funnier,
you'd be like, well, no.
You're nuts.
Or most of you today
would be like, yeah, I'm
funny enough as
it, which is what
I got from the raise of hands.
You're like, no, no no we're
all fine in this department.
But comedians over time, they
all become better writers.
So if I said to you you
can become a better writer,
you'd say, well, of course.
I just need to do a
little bit every day.
And that's effectively
what they did.
So over the course
of the year, I
guess there was really three
key findings [INAUDIBLE].
So I studied all the
leading TED Talks.
I studied all the most
popular business talks.
And we were trying to find
trends for humor in there
because no one had done it.
And I was like, well,
surely everybody
says humor is a key part
of talks, but is it?
So sure enough, it was.
All these top speakers
were using humor.
They were using the exact
same techniques as comedians,
even though a lot of
them did not know it.
And the nice thing for only
the four people in here
that weren't funny, you don't
need to be a natural comedian
to get laughs.
I remember being at a comedy
club out in Pleasanton.
And we were sitting
there, and this guy
was literally the
most boring dude
I've ever met in my
existence, like barely
conversed with anybody, just
sat there super awkward.
And I was like, well, is
it your first time coming
to this comedy club?
Are you enjoying it?
He's like, no, I'm
here all the time.
It's like, oh, what?
He's like, yeah, I'm up next.
I'm one of the comedians.
It's like, whoa, this is not
going to end well for you.
No.
Did your friends tell you
to do this as a career?
And this is a really bad choice.
No, no, no, no, no.
He went on stage and
absolutely crushed it.
I mean, people were
belly laughing.
I would have bet my house
on this guy not being funny,
and he was amazing.
And he was far from
the only guy I saw this
over a period of time.
So people who weren't
naturally funny, chatty,
witty, or outgoing off stage
were very funny on stage.
And I was like, how
are they doing this?
What are they learning behind
the scenes along the way?
And why would you need to do
this in a business setting?
We're obviously here
at Google today.
A lot of you guys are
giving business talks.
Why do you care about this?
Well, John Medina's work on this
is all around brain science,
but it's essentially the
brain doesn't pay attention
to boring things
or dodgy accents.
If you can't understand me or
you don't like what I'm saying,
you have your phone for
company at any moment.
And you will whip it
out and let me know.
Comedians, they say, are
judged about every 12 seconds.
And we're pretty much doing
the same to business speakers
these days because
you're like, I've
got a computer in my pocket.
I do not have to be listening
to this fellow who's
boring me to pieces.
All right, and they're
never intentionally boring
their audience to pieces.
Nobody goes on
stage to be boring.
They just don't really
know the techniques
behind that that
can change it a bit.
So infotainment,
basically, all of a sudden,
has become our means
for getting information.
So if you're competing
with where people
go for entertainment
to advertise or get
your content out there, whether
it's public speaking or written
content, then you
these days have
to become that entertainment.
Because I'm just scrolling
through it on Facebook.
And if you're trying to
get my attention there,
I expect it to be some way
engaging or entertaining.
So do any of you guys watch
the old school news anymore
for news?
Not so much.
Does anyone get their news
from somebody like this guy?
[CHUCKLING]
Historically, right?
I mean, that's the way
we're getting information
with a punch line.
Did anybody see on late night
TV recently any political stuff,
annihilation of Donald Trump
in one way by a comedian?
They released some of
President Obama's footage
today, talking
about his objections
to the Republican candidates.
It was basically
stand-up comedy.
It was amazing.
The timing was there.
The principles were
there, everything.
And most of the time
he has comedy writers
writing his talk.
That's why they're really good.
Obviously he has to get
good at delivering them,
and he has some huge
natural skill there.
But a lot of people
will say, well,
humor isn't
appropriate at my job.
If the president's using humor,
you're probably going to be OK.
All right?
So you can replicate
these techniques.
Anyone familiar with
Seth Godin's work?
Very, very leading marketer,
author, and blogger,
you name it.
His talks are so good
that even TED themselves
described him as funny.
They're not my words.
They're from TED's
description of his talk.
And they're really,
really funny.
When you actually
analyze his TED Talks,
you get 3.4 laughs per minute.
And that won't mean a
lot to you as a metric
until we compared
them to the three
funniest movies of all time.
So if I wanted to get
laughs per minute,
I would be better off
listening to a business talk
and watching it than I would be
the funniest movies ever made,
which is totally insane
when you think about it.
Now, we're in Google.
I know there's some good
statistics heads in the room
here.
You'll be like, well, it's a
longer period in the movie.
It's harder to sustain a
consistent level of laughs
with a story arc.
Absolutely.
I belly laughed
during "The Hangover."
I didn't belly laugh during
the TED Talk, absolutely.
But if you wanted just to laugh
on a laughs per minute basis
and get some good
laughs in, you're
better off watching a lot
of TED Talks these days.
And his talk was
by no means alone.
The good news for
us as people who
are trying to pull something
out of these techniques
is that 58% of his
laughs in that talk
came from using funny images.
So if you're like, I
can't be a comedian--
and I'm not telling anybody
in this room to be a comedian.
I'm just saying there's a
lot we can use and learn
from the techniques
that they use.
Using funny images,
stuff that you
know is socially proven and
funny already and just sticking
it into your presentation,
is one of the easiest ways
ever to get laughs.
And these guys are using it
at the very highest level
in TED Talks.
But it gets treated
very much like a joke.
So a joke is always a set-up
to something and the funny bit.
So a lot of business speakers
will put the image up there
and just go, look at that.
It's funny, isn't it?
And it gets a little
bit of a laugh.
But if you build up that
image, like everything,
the frustration I felt
that moment can all
be described by this one image,
and it's just something crazy,
always a big laugh.
And you literally just treat
the funny image or the content
you have as the joke.
You're not the one
delivering the joke.
You just build up
anticipation to it.
So the cool thing,
when we go into this,
and we link the
techniques he's using
and the techniques that a
lot of TED Talks are using,
every single one of the top
10 TED Talks at the moment
has humor in them.
Every one of them moves
the needle on humor,
and some of them at levels
that rival a stand-up comedian
and many of them
at levels that are
higher than the funniest
talks of all time.
So there's a bunch
of them interchanged.
These are researchers.
These are not
stand-up comedians,
from Sir Ken Robinson, the most
viewed TED Talk of all time,
literally to Shawn Achor,
Harvard researcher, one
of the funniest TED
Talks you'll ever watch.
I think it's the
11th most viewed
at all time at the moment.
Does anybody know Mary
Roach's talk, particularly
about female orgasm?
Any guys in the
room know that one?
[CHUCKLING]
Not one of you?
Just one you-- smartest
man in the room.
This is a very good time
to say I know that talk.
I love that talk.
Actually, I start every
day with that talk.
That's how I prepare for life.
You'll be a very popular
man in the dating cycle.
List that as your
most common interest.
I like soccer and Mary
Roach's talk about orgasm.
You will see the undying dating
spike come pretty quickly.
But the proof is there when
you go through all these,
and we did.
And we were correlated them.
They're all funny.
They're all entertainment.
And TED themselves are called
technology, entertainment,
and design.
The entertainment
level is there.
My argument was that it's just
getting higher and higher.
And if you're a
speaker in any way,
and you go on after one of
these really funny folks,
you're going to
know all about it
if you're not able to reproduce
some of those contexts.
Anybody had that
happen in a conference
where you go on after
the really funny speaker?
You're like, oh, no.
You see them crushing it.
You're like, oh no!
I don't want to go next.
How do I do that?
The thing is you
can if you know some
of the techniques behind it.
So what I'm going to give
you a little overview
is very much 80/20.
So what was I doing fast?
How was I trying
to break it down?
Again, very influenced
by trying to find
the 20% of the things I
could do that would give me
80% results in the
fastest time possible.
So starting with a story
was pretty much the basis
for me doing this.
And that was for a
number of reasons.
But if you're public speaking
in any way and you're not using
stories, well, then you're not
memorable in any way because I
cannot recall the information
you've just given me as a bunch
of numbers, facts, and figures.
If I tell you a story about the
customer problem, the solution
I've solved, whatever
acquisition it was,
whatever challenge
that you're working on,
now my mind can actually
process and remember that.
And if you're public
speaking and no one
can remember what you
said, then were you
even there in the first place?
I am today because I'm
on video somewhere.
But most of the time, you
don't leave as much of a trail.
So it's very important to
deliver your information
in a memorable way.
We know our mind
works like that.
I don't know how we have
for Spanish speakers
in the room-- any
Spanish speakers?
The word for "to put"
in Spanish is caber.
And if I'm trying to teach
someone that word-- there's
a lot of non-speakers?
Most of you guys?
Si, senor.
All right.
Nicely done.
I don't want to have
an Irish person trying
to speak Spanish in here--
never going to end well.
But if I'm trying to teach
you that word just as a word,
nearly impossible to
remember literally by itself
and to recall.
But if I give you some
context around that,
and we break it up in
a way that your mind's
able to remember
it-- so this example
I've taken from Benny Lewis
who is an Irishman who
speaks 12 languages.
And he's the first one since
James Joyce to do that.
So he's probably
worth listening to.
And his stuff is really
good around the topic.
But literally we take
the word caber to fit,
and we make up a
crazy story around it.
So we literally picture a
yellow New York taxi car,
pulling over on the
side of the street.
And then we picture
a big hairy bear
trying to get in the
window of the taxi cab,
because he doesn't know
how to work a door.
And his bottom is
taken out the window,
hairy bottom in the wind, and
the taxi driver is going crazy.
And maybe he's from somewhere
in Russia or somewhere Eastern
European.
He's like, hey, bear!
Get out of taxicab.
You cannot fit in taxi!
It's a very bad
accent, to be honest,
but it's the best I'm going to
be able to do for the moment.
And right, you're like, the
bear does not fit in the cab.
Caber, caber is the
word for it to fit.
And if I ask you
that ever again,
what's the word for
"to fit" in Spanish?
You will know it.
You won't know it instantly,
but it will take you one
to two seconds to put the
story together in your head.
So what we want to do in
trying to be funny in any way
or trying to be
memorable-- remember,
this and the book and the
objective is not to be funny.
It's to be engaging.
And the easiest
way to be engaging
is to go for fun
before funny and use
your own personal stories
because they're unique to you.
So anyone will say,
oh, I tell a joke.
You know the moment
your boss calls you,
and he's like, hey, I
got a good joke for you.
You're just like-- I know
it's not going to be funny.
I know based on historically
you just make a decision.
You see the joke
coming, and you've
assumed it's either going
to be funny or un-funny.
But there was a moment where you
had a chance to get off the bus
or get out of the office and go,
I need to get away from this.
This is going to be bad.
The nice thing when
you're telling a story
is everybody loves a story.
We've never had those moments
in life where we're like,
shut up telling me that story!
I hate stories.
All right, nobody does.
Your mind is just naturally
wired to appreciate them.
So if I'm not trying to be funny
in any way, shape, or form,
and I do it in the
form of a story that
just happens to be
funny, there is no risk
anymore to not being funny.
What happens if you
don't laugh at my story?
I just told you a
story, no downside,
more exciting than
your pie chart,
or your graph, or your
list of facts and figures,
and more engaging.
And now if we can find
out a sneaky structure
to make that story
funny, now is where
we use some comedic techniques.
The nice thing about your
stories are extremely unique,
personable to your own
style, and literally
can't be copied by anyone else.
They're yours.
And the really nice thing
with public speaking
for the nervous public
speakers out there,
when you're telling your
story, your own stuff,
and you screw it up, and
you say something wrong
or you leave out
something, what happens?
Nothing.
Nobody knows whatsoever that you
just messed up your own story.
You're the only person
that knows that content.
And you don't have to
stock with your stories.
You can draw on things that
you really like around.
But if it's your stories,
ultimately your audience
wants to know a
little bit about you.
And your stories make it cool.
They get to know you a bit.
They get to feel
for you, and they
get to relate to you
in a little bit way.
The most powerful thing you
can ever do with story telling
is to allow the listener to see
themselves within your story.
So if you do that in
any way, shape, or form,
you're already creating a memory
that they're like, oh, yeah.
I remember.
I felt something
during that talk.
So literally, when we're
trying to be funny fast,
80/20 principle style, we
take a list of our stories,
and we put them through
comedy writing techniques.
So if I say to you now,
tell me a funny story,
you'd be like, no.
And that's what everyone,
even a comedian,
someone who's performing a
story, tell me a funny story
right now.
Automatically the
mind goes blank.
I've got nothing.
And honestly, if I ask
you, tell me a funny story,
do you have anything in life?
Most of you will be
like, oh, I don't know.
What comedians and performers
are amazing at doing
is literally keeping a list
on a smartphone or device
that's like a funny story file.
And every time they see
anything remotely funny,
they're like shut up.
Stop.
I need to make a note
of this, and they do.
And every time they
listen to a podcast,
or NPR, Snap Judgment, a
storytelling series, every time
they see a stand-up comedian and
it jogs a memory in their mind,
they write it down.
And all of a sudden, you
have a mountain of material
from your own life that's
highly personable to you
that's more engaging than
the average little factoid.
And you can link
those and literally
build your own
presentations around them.
And that's what we were seeing
in the most successful talks
when we were studying, that
these guys were a shoe horning
stories they like to
tell, just in linking it
to business topics.
And you'll always say, I'm not
sure there's a way to do that.
And in the book, I listed
all sorts of ways to do that.
But any story about
anything that you think
is not appropriate you
can link that to work,
absolutely, no problem.
So we were taking
these lists of stories
that everybody thinks
they don't have.
At the moment, are you still
like, oh, I don't know.
I got nothing funny.
Most embarrassing thing
that ever happened to you?
First date you ever went on?
First blind date
you ever went on?
Strange Skype call
with your parents
where that drove
you crazy trying
to teach them how to work Skype
or trying to turn on the video?
Inappropriate text messages
you received by accident
from your friends or when
somebody just had to retype,
the respell, the autocorrect
on there do it for them?
That time you tried to
learn a new language
and you said the wrong word,
and it didn't end so well.
First day at work.
Strangest customer
you ever came across.
All of a sudden you're
kind of like, OK.
Yeah, I know.
I definitely have stories.
And they're the coolest stories
because they're relatable.
So if I tell you a great
story about me being in China,
you're like, that's great.
I don't care.
Unless you've been to
China or you're Chinese
or you're interested
in it, I need
to give you a reason to get
on board, that you relate to
in a way.
So an opening set up becomes
very important to allow
you to tell a story.
So if I tell the story
about China, don't care.
But if I can make that
relatable to you in a way
that you all go, OK, so if
I'm like, being in a new place
can be challenging, being in a
new place can be uncomfortable,
this time I was in China--
now your opening statement
was appealing to the whole room.
You didn't shut everybody off.
And you're very
much not just trying
to be Jerry Seinfeld
or something
by making a comment that's kind
of controversial or Louie CK
and be like, Oakland
is a crazy place!
And then people are
like, oh, no, no,
from Oakland in the room.
You just lost half the room.
And while comedians will
do what their skill is,
they'll bring that back.
And everybody laughs in the end.
It's all happy.
We as business
speakers are not going
to be doing that whatsoever.
Stay away from it.
We just tell stories.
There's no strong
opinions in them.
You have no chance
of running the risk.
And that way there's
no nervousness
when you're using it in
a business environment.
And to do that, we literally
just put it through a structure
that comedians use all the time.
So the reason to tell
the story, what's
the key funny part in the story,
and then any other little lines
afterwards that are kind of
engaging or funny that you can
say.
So a comedic delivery
can always be
refined to a set up,
the punchline which
is the funny part of your
joke, and then the tagline.
And comedians will
literally force themselves
to be really concise.
Business speakers, not so much.
Comedians are losing
people every 12 seconds,
so they get very good at
delivering that content very
fast.
And obviously for a business
audience with these techniques,
in any way or
anyone speaking, you
don't have an unscheduled
amount of time.
You've got to be pretty
tight in your content.
But again, we're
going to take that,
and we're going to
rewrite your story
to delay the funny
component in your story.
You ever seen somebody getting
a laugh on the business stage,
and then the whole audience
laughs, and they keep talking?
And then the whole audience
stops all of a sudden
to listen to them.
Why?
There's a really cool
expression that's
called the end of
laughter is followed
by the height of listening.
So the most attentive
your mind will ever be
is that moment after you've
laughed because you're like,
give me more of that!
Compared to your average
business conference
you've been to, you're
like, oh my god.
Wait, was that funny?
That was good.
I want more.
I need more of that.
And you get really, really
attentive to the next words.
So comedic performers,
and comedic copywriters,
and anyone who's good, did you
ever see somebody on stage,
and you're like his,
delivery was amazing?
He has really good timing.
Comedians, you're like,
that was really good.
President Obama, the video
today that I watched,
all the comments--
timing was amazing.
But you can impact that timing
by taking out the funny bit
and sticking it at the
end of the sentence.
Literally, what's
the funny word?
And how do I hide
that till the end?
And if you say the funny word
last, second to last, last two
or three words,
then you just stop
and you allow people to react.
If it's your story,
you know more or less
where they're going to react.
You've told it to
your family before.
If you had to force it to one
key element, what would it be?
You kind of know that people
might laugh or respond on this.
And now you literally
go out of your way
to structure the sentence so
the key word is at the end.
When the key word is at the
end, you just kind of sit back,
and you're like, yeah.
And you let people allow
that time to react.
And when that happens,
everyone goes away.
And they're like, his
timing was really good.
I wanted to show you a
great example of this,
and it was from
President Obama himself
in Congress, delivering it.
But it's very hard to get
the copyright permission
to show you that video,
so what I've done
is I've basically
convinced a friend of mine
to recreate it
for you, and we're
going to watch a very
low quality, low budget
production that
took approximately
six seconds to put together.
And you're going to notice
that in this, President Obama,
well, to be honest and frankly
truthful, he's Indian in this.
And we figured, well,
with the growth of tech
and the demand for
programmers in Fremont,
it's only a matter
of time before you
have an Indian
president anyway, so you
should be comfortable
with that, that's fine.
Good!
So just have a look at this.
But this is the
actual words that he
said in Congress that day,
and just pay attention
for how good the timing
is going to look.
Very high budget.
And then there's my
favorite example.
The Interior Department
is in charge of salmon,
while they're in freshwater.
But the Commerce
Department handles them
when they're in saltwater.
I hear it gets even
more complicated
once they're smoked.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, completely terrible
with awkward look at the end
there.
That's my friend Richard.
He is a programmer at Yahoo.
He's a also very, very,
very, very funny comedian.
But unfortunately,
we had to work
with the actual words in that
because we wanted to recreate
it accurately for you guys.
But you notice
the word "smoked,"
he's really gone out of his
way to put it as the last word.
And when you look up
that video for yourself,
the actual real
video of it, you'll
see President Obama just
kind of kicking back.
Because he knows
what's going to happen.
They're going to laugh.
And if I said, and when they're
smoked, it's even more crazy,
or when they're smoked
it's even more insane,
or when they're
smoked something,
once I say the word "smoked,"
you know it's a joke.
You start to laugh.
I keep talking.
You stop laughing.
And you start listening again.
So I've actually
stopped the laughter,
so my timing looks really bad.
So it's just one
little sneaky hack
you guys can use
yourself to recreate it.
Find a key part in the story
and place it at the end.
Leave it as a surprise.
And a really key thing in
comedy, which is tough for me
to talk about as an Irish
person because we're not
very good at saying
the number three,
every time in fact
we say three, it
doesn't really come
out like it should
and sounds a bit strange.
But the rule of three, if any
of you know it or any of you
have copywriting positions
here in any way or watching,
the rule of three is at
the heart of everything
memorable you've ever been
subjected to in any marketing
or copywriting
material, because three
is the smallest
amount of numbers
your brain can recognize
as a sequence or pattern.
So if I give you one, two,
you're always expecting three.
And I remember when I
looked at this first,
I was remembering when
I used to box when
I was in college or
back before college.
It was always one, two, right.
And you would always hit them
with that left, left, right,
because they weren't
expecting the right.
And that was the sequence
that you were always
trying to punch in.
It was one, two, and
you automatically
expect the third one to come
from the same direction.
Comedy is extremely similar.
It's always that
one, two, three.
And in comedy, three is funny,
because three is actually four.
So a joke is always one, two--
you think three is coming,
but it's not.
It's four.
It's a flip of expectations.
So to describe it is
very much like a train
coming down the tracks
with the first two
elements in the sequence.
I'm trying to create a
picture and let you think
you know where it's going.
And your laughter will
come when I derail or flip
that expectation.
So literally just changing
the last word in that sequence
will make it kind of funny.
It might not be viral
hilarity by any means,
but it will be more engaging,
whether it's copyright,
whether it's your
own Facebook updates,
whether it's for
Twitter, or whether it's
for public speaking.
Any information in sequence
of three is more memorable,
and it's also more
shocking to your mind
when that third element
in that is a flip
and it changes the expectation.
I mean, this is a
really good graphic
that shows how central
the rule of three
is to everything that we're
doing, from all the campaigns
and slogans you've been
subjected to, to marketing
copy that you're
like, oh, I recognize
that, to the strikes and the
sporting systems we go through
and all the sports you watch.
You remember Snap, Crackle,
and Pop in the world of cereal
when you're a kid or
the Three Little Bears.
Like, why was it always three?
There was always three of
these items, whether it's
their primary colors, to
literature, and to company
names, to TED themselves.
These names are not
three words by mistake.
They're three words
very intentionally.
Obviously here Google
just went, nah.
Google, fine.
But a lot of these
companies were not
as creative in that
endeavor, and they're
playing on the same mind
pattern of recognition for you
to remember that.
Now here's a good
example I didn't
have to go too far to find.
It's down from the
Tenderloin in San Francisco.
Some of you will be worried
about what I'm about to show.
Don't worry.
So just a sign outside a
bar-- not amazingly funny,
but you're like, oh,
that's kind of funny.
And you can replicate
this sequence in any way.
We used to do it to sell tickets
for events we were doing.
We're like, buy your tickets now
and get a free drone, a Tesla,
and false advertising.
And they're all like, ha-ha.
Buy a ticket.
It works.
And a little spike of dopamine
gets you a bit happier.
And it's a little bit of a
laugh that wasn't hard to get.
What happens if I
change that sequence?
So that's very much
one, two, four.
And that's the best
example of it there.
One and two, logical sequence.
I think I know what's coming.
Four, flip of expectation.
And so the third element,
essentially, becomes a four,
just to throw you
off a little bit
and not be able to
recognize the pattern.
What happens if I move false
advertising there and change
the sequence?
Not funny anymore, not
even mildly entertaining.
I mean, you can
use this anywhere
once you're start familiar
and start mining to use this.
So this is the back of my book.
And not much entertainment
value, traditionally,
to the back of a book.
Normally you have
a couple of blurbs
from famous people going, oh
my god, book's so amazing.
Read it, whatever.
You don't pay attention to it.
We use it as an
opportunity for humor.
So one and two there,
pretty much normal.
Three, "This book is great.
I haven't read it yet,
but David drew a picture
when he was 6 years old
of a penguin drinking
beer in a Chinese
restaurant, and it
was clear the potential
for slight wisdom
and misguided
creativity were there,"
Marita Nihill, David's mother.
Is that unusual all of a sudden?
Now you're thinking
my mom's kind of cool.
And to be honest, she is.
And she's pretty funny, if
I inherited any of that.
You guys are already
funny already.
So you got lucky as well.
But one, two, four.
So your mind's just logically
processing information,
and it comes as a
little bit of a shock
that you broke the pattern.
That opportunity's
in everything,
at the end of the emails
you send, in subject lines
for emails, and autosign--
anything we have squeezed humor
into places where
you don't expect it.
And if you're worrying
how to sequence it,
it's always that
structure of three.
So I want to show
you a quick example.
This is from a comedy club.
I wrote this joke.
It is terrible.
It is the worst joke ever.
I'm embarrassed to
even show it to you.
Even my own friends
are like, oh no, no.
Don't be telling
that joke again.
But I wrote it with
this sequence in mind.
So I'm like, if I sit down
to take a story from my life
and write it in a joke
format and I go and tell it
in a comedy club
or on any stage,
and then I go to another
one and I tell the same one,
I tell the same one, can
it become predictable?
Can it be repeatable?
And what effect will
it have on people?
And what I'd like
you to note is just
the structure of how I do it.
Has he hid the last word
until the end or not?
And you might not
think it's funny.
You probably won't.
And I'll have to explain why I
think it's mildly funny after,
but just note the
audience's reaction.
And apologies,
again, for this joke.
Because it's really terrible.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I don't know a lot about
California, I must admit.
But does anybody else
have this problem?
Guys, you're going to have with
your girlfriend-- she's always
on you to go to Napa. (FEMALE
VOICE) I want to go to Napa.
I want to go to Napa.
So I gave in.
I was sick of listening to her.
I said, all right.
And I finally brought her, and
it turns out she doesn't even
like auto parts.
[LAUGHTER]
--auto parts.
--even like auto parts.
[LAUGHTER]
--auto parts.
[END PLAYBACK]
That was totally terrible.
I did apologize.
For those of you
who don't get it,
and of course, if you're
not familiar with here
in the Bay Area, you might not.
Napa, famous wine region.
When I mentioned the word Napa,
girls are automatically like,
oh, that warm day.
I had my nice dress on.
I can nearly taste the wine.
Oh, I really like Napa.
And maybe they've even
grabbed a memory already
of when they were last there.
A lot of guys will be
like, oh, that time I
got dragged to Napa.
I'm sick of going with my
girlfriend there all the time.
But all of a sudden
you're painting a picture
of a place that is
very much not what
I'm talking about in that joke.
So it was a rubbish joke,
but NAPA, of course,
is also a chain of
automative service stores
where you go to get the
oil in your car changed,
not a good place to
bring somebody on a date,
even if you are watching
that talk all the time
about the female orgasm.
You still won't get away from
bringing the lady to the oil
parts place.
So that's the flip
in expectations.
So you're like, why is
this thing humorous?
If I wrote it out, it
doesn't seem that funny.
But very much the last word
is at the end of the sequence.
And that's what brings
it to life a little bit.
It sounds totally crazy.
But in it's simplistic
form, that can be recreated,
and it can be used
for all content
that you're crafting, whether
it's on the back of a book.
I just like that cat, and
that's why I put him up there,
for no apparent reason.
But a lot of stuff
around public speaking
that I have in the
book, a lot of it
is tips on the actual
delivery yourself.
But I wanted to talk to you
about the content side of it
at the start, how to
craft it, just so you
have a bunch of cool
material that you feel, OK, I
have an embarrassing story,
or have a crazy client story,
or have a customer story.
Because we wouldn't be
in business if we weren't
solving some sort of problem.
So you're like, who was the
person I was solving it for?
Now tell me about
them a little bit.
That's your story to start with.
So a lot of pitches,
and you'll have
heard before where they go
in-- they're just numbers.
80% year on year growth
rate, whatever attraction.
Brian, my partner,
pivoted refinance series
B. You're like, what
are they talking about?
Totally lost.
Start with a story,
and then the numbers
become the icing on the cake.
So once you give
people something
to latch onto and
remember, you're good,
a little bit of a shared
experience if you can,
so they can see themselves
within your story,
and understand the pain point
you're solving in any way,
or what you're trying
to communicate,
and then all the numbers come.
And guess what?
If you're pitching with
numbers the same thing
as comedic effect and timing,
if your company is getting
an 80% year on year growth
rate, it's much more impactful
if I say, we have a year
on year growth rate of 80%.
The impactful word gets moved
to the end of the sentence,
and it doesn't sound
as natural to say,
but with a tiny bit of
practice, it feels all right,
and it sounds totally
natural to your audience.
But I'd love to
take some questions
from you guys as
to-- there's all
this stuff around the delivery.
Obviously I pretended to
be a comedian for a year.
That probably threw up a
couple of wacky things.
I mean, the book is
very much my story,
what happened with
all this stuff,
and then how to
replicate it, and how
to do it by using comedians'
techniques to do it.
So what are comedians so
good at doing on stage
that the average
business speakers
don't learn because
they're not clocking up
10,000 hours on stage.
So is there anything you
could do or replicate?
So I'd love if any of
you guys have questions.
We do have a microphone.
There is one, I guess,
I got asked quite a bit.
Does anyone fear
going blank on stage?
Has that ever popped
up for anyone?
I see a lot of head nods.
I think the single
biggest thing I
learned in the whole year I
learned from Richard, actually,
our fake Indian President Obama
you had in the video there,
in the low budget recording.
But he taught me about something
called the memory palace, which
I hadn't heard of or I wasn't
aware of, but you might have.
Joshua Foer wrote a
very good book on it
called "Moonwalking
with Einstein,"
which essentially is a
way to remember your talk
or anything you need
to remember and never
worry about forgetting it
in any way, shape, or form.
So do you guys-- you didn't
speak Spanish earlier.
You remember the word for "to
put" or "to fit," I should say?
AUDIENCE: Caber.
DAVID NIHILL: Caber,
nearly everybody,
pretty much everybody.
Can't test you guys on the
livestream inside of it.
But you won't forget that story.
That's just the
way you wrapped it.
And it even gets more
powerful of a memory
if you take that story and you
put it in a specific location.
So if I ask you guys, have you
got a favorite restaurant you
like in San Francisco or
the Bay Area and picture it,
and be like, when I walk
in, where's the server?
How many tables are there?
Where's the bathroom?
It's very easy for that
to come to your mind.
And you're like, oh no, there's
like six tables on the left.
The server's on the right.
OK, I get it.
So if you take a space like
that that you remember easily,
now make it something
super familiar,
like your house or your
office, or somewhere
where you grew up in.
And you plant all
these little stories
as memories within
that structure.
All of a sudden,
now you're never
trying to remember a word.
You're trying to
remember a location.
So you're on stage.
And you're literally like,
where am I in the talk?
I'm in the kitchen.
Who's in the kitchen?
OK.
Those crazy memories I
planted there is a story.
So if I'm going to talk about,
say, Mexico and economic growth
and I need to remember
the GDP of Mexico is 11%,
I'm literally going to
picture a Mexican guy.
I open my door.
And there's a guy from
Mexico on a donkey,
and he's got no
pants on whatsoever.
And he's a bottle of Guinness
in each hand for no reason
whatsoever, and he has
a soccer Jersey on him.
And 11 is the number
on the jersey.
So the first thing I need
to talk about is in my talk,
I open the door.
I'm starting to
talk about Mexico.
I hope I have the image of it.
Oh yeah.
So remembered the story I
told you I told for The Moth
for 1,400 people?
That's all I had
in my back pocket.
And it stays in my back pocket.
I never take it out in anyway.
Because if you have any
notes, people automatically
assume that you didn't prepare
for this, whether you want
them to get that idea or not.
And that's all I have.
And you'll be looking
at thinking, that's
a bit of a strange story.
What are those notes?
Potatoes, 69, cookies,
fireworks, Lululemon pants.
It was about my mother
coming to San Francisco
as a conservative
kind Irish lady
and getting a lot
less conservative
and going home wearing
like Lululemon pants
and getting a bit of a taste for
weed cookies, which was pretty
interesting, to say the least.
But all I've done is I
positioned a little story
in every location in my room.
And the nice thing is when
you're doing your talk now,
you're not looking at
a list of bullet points
anymore and trying
to remember them.
And the really cool thing
is when you do this,
and you realize, OK, this works.
I actually can't forget
this stuff anymore.
Then you can sit in the audience
and watch the three speakers
before you.
So have you ever
been to a conference
or done public speaking
and someone went on
and they talked about
the exact same thing
that the last guy talked about?
And you're sitting there
going, why is he saying this?
Why doesn't he argue with
the last guy's point?
Or why is he saying
the same thing?
And the answer is
normally because he
was backstage sweating,
reading off a load of notes.
And he wasn't totally
confident that he
was going to remember it, and
the easiest way you'll ever get
laughs if the really funny
guy goes on before you,
then you just talk
about how funny he was.
And you make the same
jokes that he did.
In comedy, they call
that a call back.
And you just use something
that already worked.
But when you know
you're not going
to get to go blank on stage, the
shaking and the sweating calms
down a lot before you go on,
because you're like, all right,
the biggest single fear, I've
just taken that off the table.
And this works 100% of the time.
I've never gone
blank using this.
Any of my friends
that have used this
have never gone blank using it.
So it's a big topic by itself,
but to be honest, that's it.
Just draw out a
floor plan and create
a little memory of something.
Put it in each place,
and that's your talk.
And when you get really
good at doing your talk,
if you've ever spoke at
a conference, some of you
might relate to this where
it's a 25 minute talk.
And they're like,
actually-- just
before you go on-- everybody
else ran over a bit.
If you can just do 11 minutes.
That'll be fine.
You're like 11 minutes!
I've got like 50 slides.
What am I going to do?
When you get really
good at doing this,
you know how long you're going
to have to spend in each room.
So I know if I go
into the bathroom
and I'm talking about
the intellectual capital
of California that is
Stockton, for you guys
there, that's literally
going to take me a minute.
So I'm like, all right.
I'm not going into the bathroom.
I'm going to walk straight
through the kitchen,
and that's going to take another
two minutes off the time.
And all of a sudden, you
become very, very flexible
with what you're doing.
So I'd say of all the
tips and the takeaways
I got for the world of business,
or any form of public speaking,
this is number one for
me because it allowed
me to relax quite a lot.
Still nervous beforehand,
still sweating, but got better
about managing it, and I knew
like the ultimate fear was
gone, like me to stand there
and be like, what do I do?
All of sudden you get
a lot more comfortable.
There were loads of little
tips like that along the way
that I was getting from
performers and comedians
that I'd never, ever seen
in the world of business.
Any other kind of
wacky questions?
AUDIENCE: You did that
by drawing it out?
DAVID NIHILL: Yeah, definitely.
AUDIENCE: Or you picturing
yourself in the space?
DAVID NIHILL: I draw
it out just to help me.
But I literally sit down
and visualize myself
walking through the house.
And the crazier the
stories I concoct, kind of
like the bear in the taxi cab
and give it the extra detail,
who's the person,
put some celebrities
in there, anything, the
crazier that story becomes
that you create for
each bullet point,
and then I just draw it out,
just as literally something
to visualize that morning.
And to be honest, once maybe
I'll run through the talk
in fast forward.
And if I can't say
the word really fast,
I definitely can
say it really slow.
It was a really good thing
that someone taught me.
Like when you put a quote in
a presentation, you're like,
now I'd like to share a quote.
And you're like, I
can't even remember
what the quote is because
it's not as familiar as you
thought it would be to you.
And you can't say
it really fast.
If you can't say it fast,
you can't say it slow.
I think that was one of the
better tips somebody gave me.
Someone also said
along the way, you
know, filler words-- Irish
people are great for mumbling,
no offense Irish people
who are watching,
but we definitely do it.
And it's why I have
a hard time sometimes
with foreign languages of
sounding like a native speaker
when I'm studying them.
But the filler words that you
use, like uhh, eh, but-- anyone
ever have problems with that
when you're public speaking?
You watch it back,
and you're like,
oh, I said eh so many times.
But if you speak
literally like I am now,
10% to 15% higher than normal,
it sounds totally normal to you
guys.
I feel like a lunatic.
But it looks really,
really natural.
And you know what happens?
It's nearly impossible
to say uhh really loudly.
You just don't.
And all of a sudden,
the words come
slower because you're
talking faster,
and there isn't a
single filler word.
And you've just cured that
problem as well straight away.
I got that from
comedians as well.
All these little
things they were
doing, that I was
thinking business speakers
had never heard of.
Like coming out to
a crowd and just get
them to applaud for anything.
Have you ever been
in a comedy club,
and they're like, give it up
for your bar and wait staff!
And you're like,
they're charging me
so much money for drinks.
They don't even come.
And then when the comedian tries
to talk, they talk over them.
I don't want to
applaud for them.
But you do.
Give it up for
yourselves for coming out
to support live comedy tonight.
Sound familiar?
Now give it up for all the great
comedians you're about to hear.
The rule of three, the same
law that applies to copywriting
applies to your behavior.
If you do something
three times like clap,
you're more likely to do
it again later in the show.
So if they walk out, and it's
a totally flat audience, what
they do is just ask them
for a round of applause.
Just get them to do something.
Comedians, again,
amazing at doing it.
Introductions, when you're
introducing a speaker--
and that was his
point-- do you ever
have someone seen him coming
to a stage and be like,
John is a friend of mine.
John's our next speaker.
He was an early stage
investor in his company.
And every time he says the
word John, you're like,
do we applaud now?
No, OK.
Said the name again.
Do we applaud now?
No.
But comedy club-- ladies and
gentlemen, our next comedian
has been on at the Punchline.
You've seen him on the improv.
You've seen him
on Comedy Central.
He's huge.
Please give it up for,
and you as the audience
are like, [GASPS] who is it?
That's the only thing
you want to know.
The anticipation is building
to what's now the punchline.
It's the same structure.
And when I say that
guy's name, now he
gets a big round of applause
all of a sudden, in unison,
from everybody at the same time.
Small little things like
that have a huge impact
on what's going to happen.
I saw a question from yourself.
Was it, all the way-- did
you have one still or no?
Finito.
Yeah, same as don't end on
the questions and answers.
Have you ever seen that?
Or anyone do a Q&A session where
you're literally standing up
there, and the guy
comes back, the host,
similar although he's
doing it much better.
And it's literally like,
anyone got any questions?
Nobody?
And you're just standing
there as the speaker
going, oh my god.
I hope somebody asks a question
at some stage now soon.
And then he'll be like, oh, guy
in the back, like I just did.
And the guy's like,
no, wasn't me.
It's gone, straight away, no
intention of asking a question,
don't want to.
And then the speaker, they kind
of go off stage like this, OK,
thanks.
Bye-bye.
And the conference
organizer now has
to go back in and try
and edit that video
and make it look like
they didn't go away
on the flattest note in history.
So literally, you
can change all that.
A comedian would never
go out like that.
It's Steve Jobs strong
ending for a comedian.
Second strongest
joke at the start,
strongest joke at the finish,
out with a bang-- everybody
knows it's over.
And as a business speaker,
all you have to do
is say I'm going to take a
few questions and answers
before making my conclusion.
And if nobody asks a
question, who cares?
I still have a
slide, which is going
to have how many takeaways on it
that you're going to remember?
Three.
Still cannot
pronounce that word,
but now I control the ending.
So all of a sudden, I
know it's going to end.
All of a sudden
you know it's over.
All of a sudden the host
can say, round of applause.
You guys give it.
Everybody's happy.
Makes a massive difference.
Next time you go
to a conference,
you're going to see that.
They're going to be
running around with a mic.
Nobody's saying
anything to speakers,
just standing there on stage
looking totally mortified.
And because you
can't control that,
you're leaving it
up to random chance.
So good, good tip as well.
Anything else?
Yeah?
Please.
We'll get you a microphone,
just so they can all hear it.
I better turn off my little
potato picture [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
coming to talk to us today.
DAVID NIHILL: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering how long
it took you to stop
feeling nervous on stage.
You said you did
this for like a year?
DAVID NIHILL: Yeah,
more than a year now.
Never.
And I wish someone had
told me that to start.
I was like, when
does it get good?
No.
And I'd go do
these comedy shows,
and you'd think a green room
backstage to a comedy show,
like 10 comedians are
in there, must be so
fun in there-- not
fun whatsoever.
Never.
Everyone's super nervous.
Like, they're getting ready.
They're doing their
own way of preparation.
They're still sweating and
shaking a lot of the time.
If there's consequences,
you're always nervous.
And it was just reframing
that to say, I'm not nervous.
I'm excited.
And this is what happens.
Nobody's trying to kill me
on a daily basis anymore,
so that fight or flight
moment doesn't really happen.
It happens with little
things like public speaking,
or it happens with
like a road rage
incident that leads to nothing.
It's non-threatening
things where we get that,
and you do get it
for public speaking.
And it doesn't go away.
It becomes manageable.
But reframing that in your head,
that makes all the difference.
You're like, oh, I'm sweating.
This always happens.
OK, I'm perfectly prepared.
So if you get it in
your head like, right.
If I was an IndyCar race car
driver, and I'm in the final,
and it's a championship
decider, would it
be a good idea if I
took a shot of vodka
just before I drove the
car, a shot of tequila,
to null the senses?
It would be terrible.
Public speaking is the same.
Like if something
happens in a room,
you want to react
to it straight away.
And you're at your
most heightened state.
That's your best condition,
when the heartbeat is going.
But you do little things
like wear clothing you know
is kind of sweat proof
so it doesn't show it
if you're getting sweaty.
If there's a microphone
in the stand,
I would never take it out
for the first 30 seconds,
because I know I'm going
to be shaking so much.
But the nice thing
is if I'm relying
on my stories and
my content, that's
what I'm using in my talk,
and I start with a story,
then I'm not going to forget it.
It's mine.
And if I mess it up,
you don't know anyway.
So I get way more
comfortable about what
I'm about to talk about.
And if I have all
that stuff memorized
that we were talking
about earlier,
and I know the logical sequence,
and I know I have one or two
things that will 100%
get people to laugh,
or I know I can
just show a video,
and the video is going
to make them laugh,
or a couple of memes, and
you get really comfortable
pretty quick.
So to answer your question,
you know, it never goes away.
And I wish people just
said that all the time
and admitted to it.
But if you reframe it, then it
gets pretty easy to deal with.
So one more question
if we have one,
otherwise I'll
just finish it up.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering your thoughts
about the choice of a story.
If you're talking
about something,
it's not exactly public.
But we have a lot of things that
are like [INAUDIBLE] 10 people.
How you're designing this
component of a software system,
or how you're marketing--
some in between.
You'd never do a TED Talk.
DAVID NIHILL: No, true, true.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But you don't tell a story
about your childhood.
It has no relation whatsoever.
So--
DAVID NIHILL: Well, I
mean, sometimes it does.
But I mean, that's kind
of a different form
because it's a
bit more personal.
There's five or 10
of you in the room.
But why are you
making this change?
So there was a really
good example at Skype
when they launched the
video conferencing component
to Skype.
Most of the staff
were against it.
They're like, that's
not our core component.
So the CEO brought into
their weekly meetings
they were doing at the time
customers who were literally
the people that were using this.
And the guy'd come in,
and he's like, listen,
I was in the military
for six months.
And the only way I kept
my relationship together
with my wife was by using the
video technology component.
We have to roll out this beta.
So if you weren't able to tell
the story of the user's problem
you were trying to
solve, they were actually
bringing in these people
and [INAUDIBLE] them.
So I think you just
vocalize who is the end user
that your problem is affecting.
Where you guys, you
always have an end user.
So your opinion is not as strong
a way of motivating people
as the story.
Why does it affect
those persons?
What was the frustration in it
for them if we don't fix this?
Vocalize that.
Now hit them with
a few solutions.
Yeah.
It tends to work.
Yeah, I better tell you guys the
end of all this lunacy for me.
And the nice thing for it,
remember this sign earlier?
The sequence of three.
This is rubbish.
You can nearly feel the
frustration in this sign
as you read it.
You're like, I've tried
comedy, but it's not working.
All right.
Roses are red.
Bacon is red.
Poems are hard-- bacon.
It's exactly like they just
gave up on the process,
but it's still kind
of funny, right?
If you try to be funny ever,
and it doesn't get a laugh,
all you have to do is
acknowledge how terrible
it was and everybody's cool.
It's that guy who thinks
he's amazing at public
speaking or doing something
in front of an audience.
And you're like, well, he sucks.
That's when you're
not liking it.
But as long as they're like,
that would joke was terrible,
wasn't it?
I'll never try that again.
OK.
Good.
We'll remember that.
It was funny last
night when I was
practicing my cat-- did not
translate to the main stage
today.
Cool.
Then everybody's
still happy with it.
I mean, the nice thing
behind it, I love this metric
and I love the little cute
baby photo, obviously, as well.
But we used to laugh
300 times a day,
and now they reckon
it's somewhere about 15,
depending on the age
bracket, 15 to 20.
So like anybody who can stick
in a little bit of laughter
there quickly becomes
a bit of a hero.
And like the average
conference, it's
not the most difficult audience.
The average conference
speaker is horrendous.
They're literally like a
group of happy dolphins
when you bring in
humor going backwards.
They're like, oh,
that was so great.
My day just got much better.
That was a book
I wrote about it,
and there's loads of tips in
there, huge amount of tips.
But if you don't want to buy
it, you can get those tips
for free, totally, just by going
to 7comedyhabits.com/80tips
and download them all.
So I'm not writing this
book to write 10 books
or become an expert
on public speaking.
I hate public speaking.
It took a lot of arm twisting
even to get me on video
and doing this one
and coming today.
Because I really don't
like to be a video either.
So I still hate public speaking.
I don't want to be
going around doing it.
But if you want to get
in touch, that's me.
I'll put that up again in a sec.
I didn't want to
leave you hanging.
Remember this story I
was done for 1,400 people
and nearly laying
an egg on stage?
And I was trying
to tell you guys
you never know what will happen
when you tell your story.
So that was pretty
much the conclusion
of my public
speaking experiments.
I did this big
storytelling competition,
and I went early
on in the night.
There were 10 storytellers.
And I was winning all
the way right to the end.
And my friends were like,
you're going to win!
And I was thinking it would
be a good end to the book
this one if I win.
And then the very last
lady went and won,
beat me like point
point something.
And I was like, aw.
There goes the happy ending.
And then two weeks later,
this guy contacted me.
And that was a manager of a very
famous comedian but was also
the producer of TEDx Marin,
one of the bigger high profile
events here.
And he's like, hey,
David, would you
like to come and tell a story
or do a talk at our TED event?
And I was thinking, that's
quite a twist for somebody who
hated public speaking.
That's pretty cool, actually.
And then before I
got carried away,
I was like, oh, wait a minute.
I have a friend,
and he's the reason
I got into all this stuff
when he suffered a spinal cord
injury.
And he just did a talk,
and I helped him craft it.
And he gave it.
And he went on after Guy
Kawasaki, like his first talk
ever, and crushed it.
And his second talk ever, he
used the techniques I used,
the memory palace there
that I taught him,
and he got written up
in Forbes about it.
And I was like, let
me send you his video.
I think you'll like it.
And the guy watched it,
and he wrote back to me.
He's like, awesome.
Booked.
Done.
If you don't mind,
we'll put him on.
I was like, no, man.
Put him on.
That's going to be epic.
So he went.
He gave that TED Talk.
That's me and him
on stage at it.
I was watching backstage.
He was the very last speaker.
He got a 51-second
standing ovation,
telling them about the
case of spinal cord injury.
the talk is called
"Little Big Steps."
And literally,
like my mother has
all her old lady
group in Ireland
watch it for
motivational reasons
because it's unbelievably cool.
And at the end of
it, he actually
stands on his own
two feet to tell
the story of how he trained
himself to be able to stand up
again, even though he
was told he never would
and proposed to his beautiful
girlfriend eye to eye.
So it was pretty epic.
So if you take nothing away
from this little random talk,
start with your
story and literally
pick out the funny
component in it
and get out there and tell it
using some comedy techniques.
[INAUDIBLE] engagement.
It's your story.
Nobody knows it better than you.
And the nice thing is,
you never know what
will happen when you tell it.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]